[Música]
el embajador de colombia en venezuela
armando benedetti presentó sus
credenciales ante el presidente nicolás
maduro este en medio del
restablecimiento de las relaciones
diplomáticas entre ambos países
congeladas desde 2019 tenemos reporte
desde caracas
perú acogió la vigésima segunda reunión
del consejo presidencial andino en la
que los presidentes miembros de la can
se reunieron para mostrar su voluntad de
profundizar su integración reactivar la
economía la protección del medio
ambiente y la lucha contra las drogas
fueron algunos de los temas principales
tensión entre brasil y chile y el
gobierno chileno condenó las
declaraciones del presidente brasileño
jair bolsonaro quien se refirió a la
supuesta participación de su homólogo
gabriel moris en el estallido social de
2019 en el país andino
hola bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en france 24 los
saluda andrés meza muñoz empezamos en
venezuela donde el presidente nicolás
maduro recibió las credenciales del
nuevo embajador designado de colombia
armando benedetti el ex senador
colombiano fue recibido con honores en
el palacio de miraflores en caracas y
previamente se había reunido en la
cancillería venezolana con el jefe de
esta cartera por otro lado fue el ex
placencia designado como embajador de
venezuela en colombia también se
encuentra en bogotá para presentar sus
credenciales ante el gobierno de gustavo
petro se trata del paso más
significativo en el restablecimiento de
las relaciones diplomáticas entre ambas
naciones congeladas desde 2019
previamente desde caracas nuestra
corresponsal daniela zambrano nos
contaba cómo transcurrió la jornada el
encuentro inició con un fuerte apretón
de manos y un abrazo entre nicolás
maduro y el nuevo embajador de colombia
en venezuela maduro él lo calificó lo
calificó como fraterno duró cerca de 30
minutos sin embargo la prensa no tuvo
acceso al salón donde se lleva a cabo un
encuentro en todo momento estuvieron en
un salón aparte viéndola del canal del
estado sin embargo a través de la red
social 'twitter' armando benedetti dijo
palabras textuales que hablaron sobre la
urgencia de restablecer lazos de amistad
que nunca se debieron romper ya
previamente a su arribo a venezuela el
pasado domingo armando benedetti había
dicho que entre los temas de urgencia a
tratar estaba la reactivación de las
sedes consulares iniciando por tres de
las 16 que se encontraban activas en
venezuela caracas san cristóbal en el
estado táchira y maracaibo en el estado
zulia de esta zona especial que se
pretende crear en la frontera entre
colombia y venezuela para lo cual habría
que hacer una legislación y por supuesto
el tema de la reapertura de la frontera
que como le decías estaba cerrada el
paso fronterizo desde hace 7 años desde
el año 2015 y la reactivación de las
relaciones diplomáticas que por supuesto
luego que él entregó las credenciales a
nicolás maduro ya estan reanudadas en
colombia campesinos y cocaleros de la
región del catatumbo la zona que más se
exporta cocaína en el mundo dicen
recibir con esperanza la propuesta de de
gustavo petro de convocar una asamblea
de cultivadores de hoja de coca para
discutir la implementación de una
reforma agraria que les permita tener
alternativas para la sustitución de los
cultivos ilícitos y así acabar con la
producción de coca en el territorio
natalia plazas tienen los detalles ever
andrade dejó las armas en 2017 lo hizo
bajo la promesa de que la
desmovilización de la guerrilla de las
farc de la que formaba parte llegaba
acompañada de financiación estatal para
ayudar en la reincorporación de los
excombatientes a la vida pacífica
ahora andrade se dedica a recoger hojas
de coca otro oficio ilegal un delito
tener que nosotros grado de esto porque
tenemos que agarrar esto porque los los
presidentes que hemos tenido no nos han
dado todavía ninguna ayuda ningún apoyo
la situación de andrade es frecuente en
el catatumbo la región con mayor
cantidad de cultivos de hoja de coca en
el mundo como muchos de los 13.000 ex
combatientes de las antiguas farc cake
que dejaron las armas al siente que el
estado de los estados entramos al
proceso
con esa alegría con esa iniciativa de
que íbamos a haber una colombia nueva
una colombia en paz que íbamos a volver
a estar todos unidos pero pues
el tema de la coca nos hace volver a
nosotros por la necesidad pero desde la
visita del nuevo presidente de gustavo
petro a la zona hay esperanzas renovadas
en la región
vemos con expectativa las palabras del
señor presidente de petro donde dice de
que no va a haber erradicación forzosa
ni fumigación sino de que va a ser algo
concertado con con las comunidades para
él fue para nosotros es de alivio el
pasado viernes cuatro llamó desde el
catatumbo a crear una asamblea de
cocaleros para impulsar la transición
económica y propuso una reforma rural
para lograrlo ya varios campesinos y
cocaleros se han comenzado a reunir en
vista de la voluntad de diálogo
expresada por el nuevo gobierno el
mandatario ha denunciado reiteradamente
el fracaso de la política antidrogas que
durante décadas impulsaron sus
predecesores una lucha que no ha
conseguido que colombia deje de ser el
primer productor de cocaína del mundo y
que ha causado la muerte de miles de
personas
la comunidad andina celebró este lunes
en lima su vigésima segunda reunión del
consejo presidencial andino y a la que
acudieron los presidentes de los países
miembros el de bolivia luis arce el
colombiano gustavo petro el ecuatoriano
guillermo lasso y el anfitrión pedro
castillo los mandatarios coincidieron en
la importancia de fortalecer la
cooperación regional también abordaron
temas como la reactivación económica y
la protección del medio ambiente
expresar la importancia que tendría para
la proyección de la comunidad andina y
el beneficio de sus integrantes
ampliar su alcance
recuperando como miembros plenos a chile
y venezuela con quienes compartimos la
herencia andina tanto el o geográfico
como el lo político en lo histórico y en
lo social
y por qué no pensar en una integración
subregional
en torno a la idea de una patria andina
alcance al hermana república de
argentina vamos a chile donde se
registró una nueva protesta de
estudiantes de secundaria que derivó en
enfrentamientos con las autoridades los
uniformados lanzaron cañones de agua
para dispersar a la multitud que se
había tomado las calles de santiago para
exigir mejores condiciones para sus
escuelas la semana pasada otra
manifestación encabezada por estudiantes
de secundaria exigía transporte gratuito
educación sexual integral pasantías
garantizadas en bachilleratos técnicos y
acceso universal a todos los niveles de
educación superior
y en otras noticias de chile el gobierno
llamó al embajador brasileño en santiago
paulo pacheco para entregarle una nota
de protesta esto luego de las
declaraciones del presidente de brasil
yer bolsonaro que en el debate
televisado del lunes en la noche aseguró
que el ahora presidente gabriel boric
encendió fuego en el metro en 2019
cuando participó del estallido social en
chile la canciller chilena antonia
urréjola aseguró que se trata de una
información falsa que erosiona la
relación bilateral y aumenta la
polarización
creemos que es necesario y esperamos que
se entienda que están acusaciones
absolutamente falsas son graves no sólo
porque acusan al presidente gabriel
boric a nuestro gobierno de hechos
gravísimos delictuales pero también son
graves para los chilenos y chilenas
siendo presidente de gabriel boric o un
presidente de todos y todas las chilenas
y a propósito de bolsonaro en brasil a
un poco más de 30 días de la primera
vuelta de las elecciones presidenciales
las encuestas siguen situándolo por
debajo de su contrincante luis inácio
lula da silva de acuerdo con los sondeos
publicados por la consultora y peque el
exmandatario tendría un 44 por ciento de
apoyo frente al 32% de bolsonaro le
siguen el laborista ciro gómez con 7% y
la senadora del centro simón tvt con 3%
mientras que en un balotaje lula se
llevaría el 50% frente al 37% del
presidente de derecha
y un fallo técnico forzó a la nasa a
interrumpir el lanzamiento de la primera
versión de la misión artemis los
responsables aseguraron que un motor del
cohete sl es el más potente creado por
la agencia presentó una fuga de
combustible lo que no permitió que la
temperatura se estabilizará para el
despegue la nasa anunció el viernes 2 o
el lunes 5 de septiembre como fechas
tentativas para el despegue la misión en
una versión futura podría permitir que
el hombre regrese a la luna según lo
planeado en 2025
wright
y no lanzaremos hasta que todo esté bien
y creo que es solo ilustrativo decir que
esta es una máquina muy complicada tiene
un sistema muy complejo y todas esas
cosas tienen que funcionar
es parte del negocio espacial y de un
vuelo de prueba en particular estamos
probando este cohete y la nave espacial
de una manera que nunca lo harías con
tripulación humana a bordo
de human and butt hasta que este
informativo en france 24 gracias por
acompañarnos los invitamos a que
continúen con toda nuestra programación
quédense con nosotros
[Música]